hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video guys
i'm here to make a big update on amc i'm
gonna discuss what happened this week
guys it's pretty bad we broke out below
the 14.5 level what does it mean what
can happen now what are the next support
levels let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys daily timeframe amc so in
my last video very quickly i was saying
that we still need some time uh the
reason being that this move down is just
very intense and after that big moves
we need time the market needs time to
recover there is a lot of damage that
has been created in investors mind and
the bullish sentiment is very impacted
and let's quickly see what happened the
past week so first i still have those
green rectangles guys that were the
good positive signals that we had so we
have this first breakout here as you can
see that gave us a nice bullish move of
20
but it's not a lot for emc guys so bears
were just at 21 sitting here guys
rejected the price back to 14.5 then we
went higher but not even as high as
before so lower highs and bears were
strong again so
right now we close below 14.5 guys it's
the first time it happened since a very
long time so i'm gonna tell you right
now what it means but first let's
understand something guys that it's not
an amc related issue all right amc is
dropping all right but the rest of the
market is dropping as well if we were in
a bull market on the global market
uh these two positive signals would have
given a much better reaction because
once again who do we need in the amc
trade for
uh these strong moves to happen again we
need asset managers we need the big
money players and guys like i've
explained to you before they were here
during this first move up
and by the way here in my last video
when i said can we squeeze again i still
believe this is a squeeze of course big
money players were there but shots
covered they didn't cover everything but
option market makers guys i can tell you
they both like crazy on the upside they
lost a lot of money and they probably
covered in this strong move up of plus
95 percent all right it's not only asset
managers buying here right asset
managers they both in the way up until 4
30 maybe 40. they didn't buy at 50 60
all right this was a short covering but
uh let's come back to what i was saying
is that we need those asset managers to
be in the trade and of course guys they
won't come until there is no good
signals sent
on the global market by you know uh the
fed for example and we know we have the
interest rate fed decision coming this
week it's gonna be very important
because we need this bullish sentiment
to be here so you're going to tell me
yeah but what about the negative beta
yes of course yes the negative beta
happened five times in the past but
remember that it was during a bull
market 2021 was a bullish year so even
when the snp was dropping we were still
bullish the bullish sentiment was here
now the bullish sentiment is not here
anymore for the first time since amc
squeezed in uh may and uh feb 21.
janna sorry end of jan whatever so what
i mean is that right now the situation
is completely different so do not expect
anything very strong on the upside as
long as we are in this situation that's
what i'm saying for quite some time i
know it's frustrating i know that uh we
expect more from amc but amc cannot do a
go against the market by itself all
right it's not it's gonna it's not gonna
happen like that we need everyone to be
in the amc trade for emc to do massive
moves up on the upside and then
everybody is going to start looking at
it looking at it and
the the bank flows will come again
so right now
we broke out below 14.5 is the first
time it's not looking good it's not
looking good
it would probably
be followed by some stop losses that are
here let's see where we open on monday
if we happen above 14.5 on monday we
still have a chance that 14.5 holds but
guys i told you that
the more a support is tested the weaker
it gets it has been tested once twice
three four five six seven eight nine
it's the tenth time we are testing it
and it didn't hold right this is a
breakout right
it's not a good breakout because as you
can see we don't have increase
any volume increase so it might very
well be a fake out like we always have
an amc totally uh possible but even on
low volume we can we saw that amc can
drop right
uh it happened here guys here the volume
was decreasing
a lot as you can see
and we still dropped a lot on low volume
so it can happen it's unfortunately my
preferred scenario for the coming week i
think we're gonna go to 12 and from
there we can expect a strong bullish
reaction why 12 because it's the low
that we had here and it's the very uh
long-term breakout level we had uh in
may 21 so it's the first support we have
and each time we arrive on the support
for the first time we almost always have
a bullish reaction so
uh i'm afraid we go to 12 but maybe not
all right guys i'm here giving you
scenarios because once again amc is very
hard to predict on a day-to-day basis uh
it's easier to make prediction on the
medium term
this is what i'm gonna stick to i can
make daily updates but i don't want to
make uh
daily predictions because
it's not working well on amc let's be
honest so let's not do that so i'm not
gonna say tomorrow we drop to 12. i'm
just saying that 12 is the level we will
probably
see maybe next week maybe in two weeks
right once again maybe not because the
volume increase is not high and this is
the positive thing once again guys as
you know i try to always show you the
positive things which doesn't mean i am
bullish right i am right now neutral and
amc between
uh so i was saying 14.5 21 last week
now i'm gonna say 12 21 i'm still
neutral guys even if we go to 12 it
doesn't mean we need to go to nine which
is the next support level by the way
which is some somehow i mean it's the
level we cannot really go below uh i
don't think we will go below 12 this
week it seems very unlikely but let's
see what happens on the global market
but uh we are in a neutral area guys
that will last all right so this is what
you need to remember this is my view
neutral for the coming weeks all right
so neutral we can go like i said in my
last video we can go to 12 then rebound
or we can go rebound but it didn't
happen and then go to 12 alright i was
saying that and i was saying that here
if we reach this resistance line there's
gonna be a selling pressure and then
probably a bullish reaction so we are
waiting once again guys my view is still
unchanged uh we need to we need time we
will probably gonna move sideways until
we reach this resistance okay and
whenever we reach it so april may uh
something like that guys
maximum june once again i'm not moving
this trend length so i'm not delaying
that it's just we don't know whenever
we're gonna break out from this triangle
all right so if
we stay at 12
it brings us to june so it's gonna be
before june and before june amc is gonna
take a direction all right
uh once again it can be on the downside
it can be on the upside but let's be
honest if we are at 12 i don't see how
it can be on the downside with the good
positive news that are gonna come from
the cinema industry hopefully if the
kobe crisis doesn't intensify again so
it's probably gonna be on the upside
guys all right and this strong moves are
still in every investor's mind so if you
have a breakout here
something huge can happen and i'm gonna
be there guys to update you with the
targets like i did before of course
okay so for now we need time
uh yeah the positive thing i wanted to
show you guys is that we have this
decreasing volume okay and look
decreasing volume increasing macd
increasing rsi okay this is macd
going higher rsi going higher volume
going lower uh bears in control mark the
price action going lower we didn't make
a new low yet but i think we will soon
so what what is this telling us is it is
just telling us that bears are out of
steam and that the bearish uh movement
is getting weaker which doesn't mean it
will not go deeper it just means that if
it goes deeper it's gonna be easy to
make it move higher because once again
the volume is not big so if there are
buyers at 12 they will create a bullish
reaction and it also means that we don't
have that much more than side to come
but once again not much more downside on
amc guys it can be easily 20 30 all
right but in terms of
levels guys we lost i mean
we lost 30 points all right so maybe
we're gonna lose three
five more points i don't know
but
there is not much more downside to come
we are close to levels where
we can only bottom guys amc the stock is
not a crypto so of course it uh it
cannot go lower than some value
so
yeah here the situation is i would
personally be a buyer at 12. uh if we go
lower i would be a buyer again
i mean we are in a situation where
averaging down makes sense we are not in
a situation where buying breakouts makes
sense by the way guys uh i'm invited to
be a speaker at the free webinar for
flow bank so the link is in the
description of this video please come
massively guys it's gonna be very
interesting i'm gonna discuss actually
exactly the situation because i'm gonna
discuss the different uh strategies we
can have to manage a swing trading
portfolio so what is the difference
between buying low and averaging down
and buying high on the breakout and in
which situation it is better to do and
what kind of profits you guys can expect
so for all of those who are interested
about how to manage a port for you guys
this is for you and for the story i'm
i'm of course an independent trader i'm
invited there because the ceo's
assistant is the wife of my cousins so
this is the reason why i'm gonna be a
speaker for them uh i'm very happy they
invited me so please guys come there
just subscribe to this link and you're
gonna learn a lot of information it's a
one-hour webinar i'm gonna be the
speaker so i'm waiting for you guys
please come there and you're not gonna
be disappointed so let's go back to amc
sideways maybe go to 12 if we go to 12
we rebound we have increasing macd
increasing rsi decreasing volume so the
bearish move is losing steam but we can
still go a little bit lower we have this
major resistance line that right now is
127 but we won't just go to 27 right now
so probably later i don't know if it's
in april it's going to be 123. we're
probably going to have a selling
reaction
first then bullish reaction and we are
waiting guys for this triangle breakout
that is for sure gonna give us some
massive moves hopefully on the upside
and i'm gonna be there to tell you what
i think last thing guys uh i wanna show
you the
synthetic shot
so nothing crazy happening there uh we
still have some synthetic shots but very
small guys close to zero at 0.8
i'm only here talking about the official
numbers of course i'm not seeing uh the
naked shorts if there is any
and there's there is probably some naked
shorts of course and the regular shot is
20 percent still the same
so we have a dtc 2.3 and march 18th
maximum pain is guys around 21 22
so it's gonna be hard to reach these
levels but just keep in mind this is the
level that is going to be targeted by
option market makers so let's see if we
are if you are lucky maybe we're going
to have some nice moves up coming here
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show see you guys